I will form a British Army intelligence
and security officer Philip Ingram is
here to give us his analysis why don't
we start Philip with this Vargo group
Convoy that's heading from rostov on Don
all the way up this Motorway here to
Moscow they're making progress well they
are and progress on day 486 of Vladimir
Putin's 10-day special military
operation it took them 18 months to get
seven kilometers in back mode they've
now done 350 kilometers in in a day but
they are making significant progress up
the M4
um and that is a direct link from rostov
up into Moscow and there's unconfirmed
reports at the moment that Wagner the
Wagner Convoy has gone north of foreign
and is about but four hours four hours
to six hours driving time away from
Moscow itself and indications that
Moscow is increasing the defenses around
the roads that lead into it incredible
isn't it so that they are meeting
resistance they have met some resistance
on on Route we've seen some pictures of
the helicopter filter that had to try
and avoid an anti-aircraft missile and
that was almost certainly fired by the
Wagner troops I've seen pictures of the
Wagner Convoy being vehicles on it being
blown up so it's clear that the Russian
military and the Russian army air
capability and the Air Force are
attacking elements of this Convoy
um that's all they've really got at the
moment but we've got Russian on Russian
yeah tell us about rostov as well
because they that they're claiming to
have taken key military command centers
there
um have that they don't seem to have met
any resistance um certainly for from
from the Russian army what about the the
public there as well what what's the
sense they're getting from them well
I've seen pictures of um the public
giving the Wagner troops
um bottles of water and leaving food by
them and all the rest of it again there
have been pictures showing
progression supporters fighting in the
streets civilians fighting with
anti-progosian individuals sort of there
in in little spots that are building up
so there's clearly tension building but
as we saw in the picture just before
this progression was sitting down there
with the deputy commander of the gru the
Russian first
um military first directorate their
Military Intelligence
um and with the commander of the
Southern command they don't seem to be
in an aggressive stance at all having
negotiation that southern command
headquarters controls all of the
operations
um into Ukraine and therefore from a
military perspective it's very important
but from a political perspective
especially the pressure being put on
um the Russian defense minister shoigu
and on the overall commander General
grazimov that is significant very
significant yeah I mean is there a sense
that perhaps those two men could meet
um uh with with a Wagner group
Representatives is that something that
that could happen by the end of the day
well pregosian's been asking for that
that's what he's saying he's saying I'm
marching on on Moscow because I want a
meeting with his beef is with them
rather than with Putin exactly and he's
been very careful in the language that
he's put out not to openly criticize
Putin certainly in the initial
um uh messages that he's putting out
there um there have been subsequent
messages and again I'm trying to confirm
that these have actually come from and
where he has called for Putin to be
toppled that's then crossed the Rubicon
um and we're then into the the Acoustics
but it's it's a fast-moving very Dynamic
um environment but it's it's being made
more complex because there's an awful
lot of disinformation being put out
around it at the moment so we have to be
very careful about latching on to
reports that say this to reports that
say that and take them with with a bit
of a pinch of salt until we can get them
confirmed yeah um good advice and let's
talk about Ukraine as well because is is
there a tactical advantage in the in the
short term in Ukraine exploiting if you
like this uh the the this vacuum I think
the ukrainians are doing the right thing
and to use their own words they're
running out of popcorn because they're
sitting back and watching it and that's
exactly the right thing to do watch what
is happening at the moment because there
isn't an immediate tactical Advantage
the Russians that are on the front line
in the in the positions defending
against the Ukrainian counter attacks
still have their mind failed still have
their anti-tank traps still have their
anti-tank weapons their artillery still
firing in they're focused on keeping
themselves alive and doing that they're
keeping the ukrainians back
um what the ukrainians could be doing is
making life harder for them by
continuing to attack their logistic
sites their Commander control sites
behind the lines so that you know at
some stage the Russians in the front
line are going to run short of or run
out of ammunition and the Ukrainian
counter attacks are going in and still
probing in uh north of bakmut
um south of Donetsk and from zapparasia
down to top towards Tomac looking for
opportunities if the Russians in the
front lines start to run out of
ammunition that's when the Russian
soldiers are going to go we can't defend
this and we have to get out of here what
I was going to ask you about that
because morale amongst Russian soldiers
has been pretty low are they now sort of
thinking watching all this weighing up
their options
um the Russian soldier hasn't got the
authority in the front line to think
like that and therefore they don't they
do what they're told
um and you they whenever they run out of
ammunition that's when it'll cause them
real dilemma because they'll go I
haven't been told to leave I've been
told to stay
um but they'll want to leave because
they've got nowhere with all to defend
themselves it's not a tactical
opportunity for Ukraine at the moment it
will be in the coming days if Ukraine
can exploit the operational advantage
and Destroy some more command and
control logistic hubs and all the rest
in Russia's rare areas yeah fascinating
I know you're uh speaking to your
contacts um behind the scenes we'll let
you go away Andy that we'll speak to you
again a little bit later